We all like to spice up our meals, but did you know that
129 teaspoons of pepper all at once could kill you?
Perhaps more concerning is that eating as little as a few teaspoons of nutmeg can induce convulsions,
palpitations, nausea and possibly death.  Of course sugar has also been linked to a myriad of diseases but for a 150-pound person
10.5 cups of sugar at once is deadly.
With that much sugar you might also develop some serious cavities, but don't go eating toothpaste.
Fluoride is very safe in small doses and can help fight cavities
but ingesting around 24 tubes with
170 milliliters or 6 ounces each could be fatal.  If you're trying to avoid wrinkles just know that
68 nanograms of Botox is lethal.  It does stand for botulinum
toxin after all.  Of course injections use a tiny fraction of that amount which prevents nerves from firing
essentially paralyzing muscle.  And while you've always been told to eat your fruits and veggies, enough oranges
And you'd be overdosing on Vitamin C. Granted you need to eat about eleven thousand at once to reach this dosage.
809 vitamin supplements would do the same. If healthy food makes you run the other way don't go too fast.
Though our bodies can handle
amazingly fast speeds we're not so great at acceleration.  The Earth is flying around the sun at around
1,600 kilometres an hour, and it doesn't faze you.
But if it started accelerating to a faster speed we'd all feel the jolt.
14 g's of lateral acceleration and your organs would start to tear loose from one another.  Running fast will also warm you up,
but when internal temperatures exceed 40 degrees Celsius, heatstroke will kick in and could potentially lead to death.
Sweating can help cool you down
but with any extreme heat dehydration
sets in
causing decreased blood flow to vital
organs like the kidneys and the brain.
As a result they begin to shut off while the intestines break down and release harmful bacteria
into your bloodstream.  Of course cool your internal temperature down too much below 21 degrees Celsius and your body enters a lethal phase of hypothermia
which causes veins to constrict and blood flow to decrease,
focusing warmth on internal organs until they begin to fail too.  If you're trying to see those internal organs try to avoid getting
7143 abdominal X-Rays back-to-back
which is enough cumulative radiation to kill you.  This ionizing radiation has enough energy to rip electrons from atoms.
5 grays of radiation is enough to kill 50% of the population
which a nuclear blast could administer.  If you're hiding from a nuclear blast to be careful of eating too many green
Potatoes in your bunker.  The green color that forms on the skin is actually
chlorophyll which isn't toxic but indicates the presence of the toxin solanine
which is a defense mechanism against pests.  You might get sick from eating one,
but eat around 25 of these medium-sized green potatoes and your life could be on the line.
What's good for our own survival in small doses can sometimes be lethal, like potassium.
Potassium ions are essential for nerve impulses and muscle contractions, but potassium chloride is also used for lethal injections.
You need to eat about 480 bananas to reach this lethal amount,
but your stomach might burst before you reach that.  Just remember the dose is the
poison.  If you want more examples of weird things that could kill you check out part 1 of this video.  You can also watch our
latest video when
scientists go to music festivals if you're looking for a good laugh and some facts and stats to impress your music-loving friends.  And
subscribe for more weekly science videos every Thursday.